sapete ormai tutti che quando vado tipo
che mettono a los angeles in giappone
quando vado in tutti i paesi del mondo
io torno con un sacco di cagate che ho
comprato è arrivato il momento di far
vedere le stronzate che ho comprato
perché da come potete vedere in questo
momento sono stronzate
e anche belle grosse comunque così
rimorchio la [ __ ] che un piacere non è
un placement ve lo giuro non è uno
sponsor non avrei un cazzo però questa
busta è veramente [ __ ] l'ho presa solo
perché faceva affondarne con la
maglietta se non nel mio sì partiamo
subito con le cagati che ho comprato a
londra number one ragazze la prima è
molto speriamo una roba semplice questa
è una birra birra finta perché se tu fai
così e gesù può accompagnare saw vi
assicuro che contavamo nel negozio broda
fare così a mia madre si è cagato
addosso quindi funziona dovete essere
pronti per questo che questa è veramente
[ __ ] ci siete vi spiego per chi non
sapesse questo è mister bean però sono
conosciute mister bean
c'è qualche problema bene non potevano
spendere questi sei pound per questo the
next one ragazzi ecco questo credo voi
conosciate tutti non sono io quando
avevo i capelli migliori di questi è
adesso sì che la [ __ ] arriva motivo per
rimorchiare ragazze si vestono che il
link line dolce gabbana
insomma smoking ste cose molto figli non
vanno in discoteca col papillon
non sarà un cazzo sempre nello stesso
negozio trovato questo che è un condono
day one direction che verrà sentito one
e one air action e sempre con questa
maschera e io vado in giro veniente così
poi la polizia arriva in cinque minuti
però ne quei cinque minuti rimorchi che
la metà basta però siccome vi dico che
casino è stato spiegare a mia madre pil
perché ho preso questa cosa crede questo
l'abbiate già anche vista quando sono
andato a londra come andato al museo di
madame tussaud non so mai come minchia
si pronunci che ho fatto una foto
con donald trump che credo l'abbiate
vista tutti ormai su instagram però me
la faccio vedere lo stesso perché merita
po tutti i biscotti li prendo sempre
perché a londra fanno questi che anche
questo non è uno sponsor ve lo giuro
per dimostrarlo questi biscotti fanno
cagare il cazzo ecco quindi non potrebbe
essere uno sponsor che ho detto questa
cosa mi fanno solo a londra che io
sappia almeno li ho visti da un lip e li
compro sempre
non avete idea di quanto è stato
difficile trattenermi dal mangiarli per
farvi di vedere prima per questi giorni
mi seguì di sale e divorati tre volte ma
serebbe dalla mia stazza però vi
assicuro che mangio un sacco di disco
sempre per chi non ha mai visto a mister
bean che c'è qualche problema se non
merita questo non so fino ad ora abbiamo
soltanto scherzato verrà assicurato è
andato anche a e gli studiosi harry
potter e ho comprato un sacco di cagate
di harry potter
se siete fan di riportano meno forte
sega perché sono delle figate a
prescinder la prima e la più bella aveva
procedere subito bene 14 pound questa
cosa vi ricordate ragazzi video che
avevo fatto tempo fa con le caramelle
tutti questi di uno ecco quelle erano le
caramelle tutti i gusti di uno ma queste
sono quelle vere perché questi qua sono
proprio quelle cazzute con la scatola
originale tutti infatti che secondo le
scarpe ero neanche perché sono troppo
troppo troppo figlia da albi che quando
sono nato io ho preso la burrobirra
marco migri di abbiamo solo burrobirra
perfetto è veramente mi hanno dato il mi
hanno versato la burrobirra in questo
bicchiere è verde che c'è scritta burro
vi era sopra l'ho dovuto pulire ma me lo
sono portato a casa i nata non potevo
però non sono portato lo stesso the next
one ragazzi ma che adesso c'è il
traghetto che ho comprato questa cosa
perché ho una sciarpa di antonio conte
va bene non mi ricordavo aver comprato
una sciarpa di nascondino contenere non
c'entra una sega
andiamo avanti su questo gesto roma
questo è un po questo genere di
amsterdam
ma perché è finito nella roba di londra
ma perché questo l'ho comprata adams
adesso venire per i miei genitori invece
col cazzo è finito nella roba di londra
siamo arrivati al punto in cui vi faccio
vedere le cose che secondo me sono le
più belle ma partiamo dalla prima
sciocco lane 9 fans tra l'altro l'ho
pagata st cioccolata la madonna
veramente la pro solo perché ci siete
buona cioccolata
ok allora scarpe stato richiamato la
princiotto lario come quando bay panini
nell'intervallo a scuola mi dà morse se
lo mangiano tutto col braccio compreso
triangolo e cioccorane agli amici
durante sfiga che sembra tipo ma da così
apre sound of health della run for hoth
io non ci credo ce l'hai cena per la
figurina di silenzio nel culo c'è
silente che figata non la sapremo sta
roba
ragazzi miei non salta però per 10 euro
poi chiama caso non mi davano un kg di
cioccolato non lo so io a te l'onore
come come segnale
[Musica]
kambewa dice il programma non programma
bene the next one ragazzi abbiamo sempre
a 10 potter ho preso la bacchetta la
bacchetta non è altro che un pezzo di
legno hanno preso un pezzo di legno dal
prato ed hanno spacciato come bacchetta
di harry potter
wow sto scherzando me l'ha regalata un
panno questa prova messa in mezzo perché
ci stava rafi come anche scritto da
bellissimo ciò anche il biglietto da zio
fanta per far vincere che zio che gli
schiamazzi o frate gioioso fa vigeva un
bel nome ma si affronta come penultimo
oggetto e questo è un orgasmo è un
orgasmo puro se non la conoscete potete
chiudere il video perché non meritata
meta non l'ho mai aperta però deve
essere veramente la figata con la elle
maiuscola
e vabbè è grossa e i compiti di
matematica possono accompagnare solo
l'ultimo oggetto che hai diviso in due
siccome tipo quando girava nel negozio
c'erano c'era praticamente questo che è
il cuscino di grifondoro che è
fighissimo solo che c'era allo stesso
tempo quello di sempre verde ero
indeciso se prendere questo o questo
allora visto quello che la mia amica lì
l'ho chiesto sono date meglio questo è
meglio questo perché questo questo
questo questo visto questo visto questo
e mentre dicevo questa cosa mi son
ritrovato qua a girare questo video con
tutti e due in mano
quindi io presenta comunque ragazzo
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
concludo qui con tutte le cagate che ho
comprato a londra non sarete mai fashion
come me e questa roba qua purtroppo è
vero ma vieni siamo tutti ragazzi in un
episodio cose un argomento è un mi piace
anche vari social che come nella
descrizione se gli si chiede e ci
mettiamo fosse un video ai ragazzi
[Musica]